all right jessica i'm coming your way
first because as an executive producer
on the project i was wondering if you
could give us a little insight into some
of the early conversations figuring out
the style and tone for the show because
i feel like i've seen a lot of shows
recently that adapt true tragedies and
they all make very distinct choices in
that department so what was it like
figuring out what the best way to tell
this story was
i i would love to say that that i could
take a lot of credit for that but i i
came onto the project after robin our
creator writer and nick
um
had written the first few episodes and
had a real vision for this
and hulu as a great partner shared that
vision so we were all on board and
collaborating very um
very much in parallel and aligned from
the very beginning
um but i think the real key that we
wanted to create was this you know this
deep sense of you know suburban
mundanity where you just
you watch these lives playing out and
it's these simple things of a baby
crying and waking up their parents in
the morning and then mom is grabbing the
baby and dad is just hanging with the
dogs and having breakfast and you're
seeing the difference of these
lives that are that are coexisting and
yet so you know million miles apart
um
so that feeling that sort of
suburban dread that kind of eeriness
that authentic looking
uh 1980s palette and
color scheme all of those things were
highly important and the whole team was
on board from the very beginning i think
also michael uppendale who directed the
pilot is so great at setting a tone
that that sustains he directed the pilot
also for castle rock a show i did a few
years ago and i just trust him and love
him so much and i really think he did an
incredible job of setting up the world
and showing how much breathing room
there was gonna be in the show like
within the performances
um so he's i just think he's the beast
absolutely you guys have a great team
here i'm a little obsessed with nick's
works i'm a massive channel zero fan and
i think he should still be making that
show if he wanted to right now but
for another time uh melanie i'm not sure
if these timelines actually match up
here or if it's release date screwing
with my brain but i remember you telling
me that you almost passed on yellow
jackets when that came around so did
this project come your way at a similar
time and if it did what made you think
this one was worth the commitment as
well um yeah i just was so exhausted
when i got offered yellow jackets i
couldn't imagine working i was in the
middle of working it was really hard
with an infant
i'm happy that i did not pass on it
this project came to me what like near
the end of the first season of
yellowjackets so i was shooting
um
the great thing about yellowjackets is
half of the episode is with the younger
cast and half of it's with us so we just
don't get too tired you get a week off
every single episode it's a dream job in
literally every way
but this came my way and i just i loved
it like i didn't think twice i love the
scripts i'm a huge fan of jess and i've
always wanted to work with her
and then michael like
a director i trust is is huge for me and
i knew that i already loved him and then
i had a zoom with
him and robin and nick and i just
everyone was just great it i just it was
a very easy easy thing to say yes to i
can understand that to make jessica
blush a little here so i get really
really excited when i see someone with a
big platform and a significant amount of
weight in this industry like one
delivering great work on screen but also
using that as a producer to help get the
projects made that they want to see get
made so what was it like working with
her not only as a scene partner but also
as a leader on this set oh i just i love
jay so much and
she just did not disappoint me
every mom as an actor
sorry to talk about you as though you're
not here but no no please
she's so
present and so surprising and it was
something
i knew would happen because i've been
seeing that in her work throughout the
years but just to watch this performance
unfolding before my eyes like honestly
when i was watching the episodes finally
i was watching it as a fan of hers like
i was so excited to see the scenes i
wasn't there for to see her at home with
tim to see her with pablo i i just think
she's an absolute genius and a wonderful
leader like taking care of everybody on
set just
just a really really kind
good person
um always like the funniest one on the
group text
tim is fine not true not true
um
but just like just making everybody feel
welcome making everybody feel
appreciated
um and just so fun to work with i just
wanted i just want to do it more i hope
we get to one day
i ask that question i always like
hearing about forces like that in this
industry
you